- Well, when you impersonate someone,
do you try to keep it from being too mean,
or do you just lean in?
- No, I think, I don't
want to hit below the belt
if I can help it.
I think we take enough digs
that you would have to be able to like,
know that you can look
them in the face someday.
- Yeah, I always think
it's an honor, though.
Like, I've been made fun of
before, and I think it's funny.
I run into people and I laugh,
I'm like, that was good, actually.
If it's good, you're like, okay.
But yeah, I don't know.
That's why I always love when
comedians host shows too,
like on award shows.
I think it's way funnier,
'cause we love-
- Yeah.
- To see celebrities get poked at.
Who doesn't love that?
I love that. (chuckling)
- Right. Well, and I
think part of me is like,
I have to kind of find things that I love
in everybody that I'm playing,
because that makes it fun to do.
And those are the things that
I like to poke the most at.
- Agreed, agreed.
Has anyone you've impersonated,
have they ever contacted you
and said like, thanks? (laughing)
'Cause you kind of, I feel when
you're impersonated on SNL,
it's almost an honor, right?
Like, it just doesn't matter
if they're making fun of you.
- That's a good way.
I think that's the
attitude to have, Kelly.
- I think so, too. (laughing)
(audience members laughing)
- Yes.
So, Erika Jayne from "Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills"
sent me golden-covered roses.
I didn't play her specifically,
but I basically played her,
a character named Candice.
And then I did Governor Whitmer
from Michigan this spring,
and she was not happy with the
choice of beer. (chuckling)
(Kelly laughing)
And so she sent me-
(laughing) So she sent a
lot of Michigan craft beer.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- She really taught me a lesson.
- Yeah. (laughing)
(audience members laughing)
- Beer's on every time, now.
- And now I'm gonna poke at you more.
So which of your characters
are you most and least like in real life?
Like, which one is like, ah,
that's actually a little me.
- Well, I have to say, so I'm
a little Cathy Anne, for sure.
I mean, she's much
harder living than I am.
(Kelly chuckling)
And then, Girl You Wish You Hadn't
Started a Conversation With
at a Party sort of started
by me making fun of myself.
(Kelly sighing)
- (laughing) I love that one.
(audience members laughing)